hello my name is Matthew Reese and I
feel equal parts confused and terrified
about being Conan O'Brien's friend well
that's uh the confusion
would be why why why am I even here to
be perfectly honest
I think you thought you were on your way
to a different podcast no no it's not
that I usually go to most interviews and
certainly most jobs going why am I here
they're just gonna go we meant Terry
Reese get out road I live my life I mean
what a way to live I mean I know what
most actors do have is that ever
acrossed your mind for a second why
should I be here yeah the Imposter of
course what are you talking I've built a
career on the imposters no I I I'm
constantly looking about saying how is
any of this happening right um and I
think that they're talking about someone
behind me and sometimes they are
actually that has happened that's that's
a terrible feeling but but I still I
still I still navigate life looking at
people like you going I bet yeah
doesn't feel it who the Revelation
recently was Ryan Reynolds says he
hasn't I was like God he has it right
well if he has it we're all fine yeah
well okay this is a a true story that
should put you at ease I have these two
colleagues that usually do the show with
me
Sona who's my assistant and uh Matt
Gourley but they have been found out
they have been found out so now they've
been removed yeah they're gone but
because I'm they both have young kids
and I'm here in New York and they found
out that you were booked and they were
ecstatic then they find out that only I
get to talk to you because it's in New
York and they talked about it on the
show and how bitter they were because uh
I hate to break it to you but uh you
were a delightful uh good-looking fellow
that everyone so this there was an
Insurrection in my little show because
they couldn't be here things I have
never sparked one an insurrection
in my in my own lunch time yes it
genuinely makes me feel like I have
something to give I this reminds me of
years and years and years ago in another
lifetime I was walking through a section
of Boston ran into a gang of kids who
were not too happy to see me one of them
uh punched me really hard in the face
smashed my nose so my mother's at work
and she gets a call and the person who
calls my mother says you're I don't know
why she phrased it this way but it was a
gang of kids and she said your son Conan
was attacked by a mob and my mother's
first thought was that makes sense
because she was just used to me being
around the house being a wise ass of
course he was attacked by a mom oh my
God she probably finished the sentence
one of your sons was it Conan yeah that
makes sense oh my God no we all have but
the fact that she thinks you you could
offend a mob or incite a mob I could do
it he's all he's almost a certain
Testament to you in a way I think it is
it shows
I'm you know yes I'm like Braveheart you
know I'm just yeah yes a great uh yeah a
leader yeah yeah yeah yeah thank you for
that you know my life has changed so
much Sona has it yeah let me tell you
how I can just get all this stuff
delivered right to my door I mean if you
grew up when I did in the early 1920s
that was unheard of you know a kid in a
cap had to hey boy boy you know and
you'd have to say yes sir and you'd have
to say you know toss him a coin go get
me that goose in the window and he'd say
yes sir Mr Scrooge but it was that was
was like back then yeah but now it's not
so much of our world digitized and
automated why stick to Old School
mailing and shipping if you mail or ship
off and let stamps.com do the hard part
for you simply print Postage and
shipping labels right from your home or
office it's ready to go in minutes no
long lines are complicated setup
required it's the easiest so it's the
best yeah postage rates just increased
again hello luckilystamps.com has the
best discounts in the industry Street
avoid the hassle and get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan people adore you and
when we talked the last time we talked
on the podcast it was Zoom because it
was during the alleged virus
um I'd still like to see proof on that
and uh and you were fantastic and we
were cackling away and then I will admit
at one point your lovely and beautiful
wife Carrie walked by in the background
with I think a load of laundry
and I have to tell you
I I my soul left my body for a minute
and I didn't listen to you at all yes I
watched this this vision of beauty
walked by with some laundry and then
walk by the other way yes my soul off
when I see her with laundry my soul
leaves my bodies I think I haven't
done it oh God you're in trouble oh
yeah that's that'll make me that'll make
me leap like noriev when I see work work
in the house that I haven't done you
know it is still a disconnect for me I'm
I'm a big fan of yours and of your work
and whether it's the Americans or Perry
Mason or any of the work you've done
film I'm just used to
uh this the accent your true accent is
fantastic though the the uh the Welsh
accent might be my favorite accent
hurray because I find the Irish accent
to be absurd
I mean the real Irish accent you know
the real Irish accent yeah you go to
Ireland and you talk to Irish people
when I was a kid there was a commercial
for cereal called lucky charm yes of
course and the little lucky trouncement
were like ah Lucky Charms all kind of
like this yeah
and I thought that's how Irish people
talked and then I talked to real Irish
people
foreign
not a word can't understand a word yeah
yeah yeah one long aggressive vowel
when was the first time you went to do
were you tracing Roots the first time
you were no I went there the first time
of course to do comedy I went there to
shoot uh a comedy piece and the idea was
that I was looking for my roots but that
all I knew was that they looked like me
meaning round face Irish red hair
um they drank a lot and they were
depressive and I was saying asking
people and their last name was O'Brien
great and of course
um it was a really fun segment but
I have found myself uh I mean I
basically know sort of where we're from
but which is where we are from the south
on the water uh dungarvan right in
Waterford yeah yeah and we know that I
have uh great great grandfather who is a
bone Setter uh and someone else was
really good at building a stone wall
and seriously like he knew where to put
the rock yeah
I could see the bone Setter and and the
wall Mason kind of discussing notes at
times yes sure surely they found a
Common Thread yes which is when you drop
the rock yes
well I'm related to him I'll send it to
him now yeah he's such a he'll set you
right yeah they probably worked with
each other they did they did but I'm
curious uh you It's gotta be
such a rich and important part of your
life because I think of
the amazing actors storytellers poets
come from Wales it's just got to be in
your blood there's something in your
there's something in the blood oh God
people what is it besides besides the
obvious yeah yes this says 90 alcohol
um
there's a number of things like
attribute it to yes I think like the
other Celtic countries we'd we have that
very deep rooted
um storytelling Society yes yeah I think
I think whales possibly more so than
Ireland Scotland because we were far
smaller in numbers and size had to had
to work that much harder and to to find
an equal footing yeah in in this in the
kind of between the two Celtic Giants so
sometime at times we we shout a little
too loud as the kind of you know
aggressive young sibling of of the tribe
um
um and I think it's certainly in Wales
where there's still a very I don't know
if I bored you this last time there's a
very strong tradition
um in in the youth movements of Wales
twice a year there are two enormous
cultural festivals four children
although he's slightly ironic that they
make it a competition right but you get
together to compete in poetry recital
um you know singing that any kind of
cultural medium so it you are you are
beaten over the head with it you know
from a very early age
this is I'm going to add to this yeah um
which is that uh I spent 28 years with
a talk show talking to a lot of actors
and I learned over time
and this is just almost like I was doing
a science experiment
that
whether you're English Irish Scottish
Welsh
um those actors come and they have
stories and they're funny and there is a
thing and it's not it's not true of
every American actor certainly but there
was uh I don't know I I have a theory
that it was maybe James Dean or Marlon
Brando
the looking down
never smiling mumbling
uh tradition meant that it's not cool to
be a raconteur right does that make any
sense to you absolutely so so so uh you
know you'd have
uh you know great great American actors
would come on and they'd give very
little be a little monosyllabic and
every now and then they dare to be a
little funny but it was almost as if
this is not our culture and there's no
training and every time I talk to
anybody who came up in the UK
they I mean you're talking about
and we were talking just before the show
about just some of the amazing crates
and you see them on talk shows back in
the 60s yeah and the 70s I was right I
was certainly raised on you know that
couple I was gonna say you know I think
I'm gonna segue viciously because I have
quite I have a mustache at the moment
because my nephew came over to stay with
me recently and I have such vivid
memories of my uncles back in the 70s
and 80s who have had terrible mustaches
so I kind of wanted to have pictures of
of us together so we'd always have these
terrible pictures of me in a mustache
because I always think you should have a
picture a photo of your uncle with a do
with a dubious mustache in somebody's
like wait a minute you're on the
Americans couldn't you have just I
thought I did think about going into
into the cigar box and going now what do
we what do we have here today I'm
Groucho Mars yeah yes uh
um that coupled so it was always the the
uncle that was the slight rack on tour
for us back at home who always came in
with a long story or the you know the
tall tale coupled with those you know
the Petro tool Richard Harris the
Richard Burtons when when they're on you
know um on those on the big talk shows
who could just spell bind with with
these stories of of such enormous
standing that you didn't care if they
were true or not oh God true has no
place in a story no absolutely we have a
saying uh it's an Irish fact you know
which is
uh and my my mother-in-law who I adore
who's great she uh her family like mine
uh is uh Irish Catholic and she'll
sometimes with great certainty tell you
a story yeah and uh my father-in-law
will say well it's an Irish fact I'm
taking that one home oh yeah well Kelly
and I because Kenny Kenny just think so
she's like yeah but that's not true and
I'm like
but that doesn't matter because the
story was infinitely better with that
fact this is because but it's not a fact
I'm gonna play this segment for my wife
because my wife and my kids are always
around they saw the the actual moment go
down right then I rearrange you yes I
make a few tweaks and I'm killing with
it at a party yes no no no no no no no
that's not true
you have the order wrong yes and no you
didn't have a shotgun and I think well
okay yeah yeah it was a pellet gun it
broke the skin yeah it shot bubbles it
shot soap bubbles yeah
um but I I saw I think footage I don't
remember where he was but I saw Richard
Burton telling a story and you know you
think about now there's just so much so
many interviews everywhere and they're
just the the world is
everybody's constantly just interviewing
each other no one's growing food anymore
yeah yeah and so um you can get like
okay you know is this really
so much fluff but then I I watched I
forget who it was but they were
interviewing Richard Burton and he was
talking telling a story about
as a young man doing
uh performing Shakespeare in London and
then he said he could hear the word had
come out just before he went out that
Winston Churchill's in the audience and
then he said he starts to say as lines
and he can hear this very familiar voice
in the audience sang them along with him
yes word for word word for word and I
think and he said I sped up I slowed
down I couldn't lose it I couldn't lose
him no no and I think to myself now
that's a talk show story yes I don't
have one like that no I have no I tell
people Winston Churchill came to a late
night show a few years ago and if no one
ever for some reason I couldn't lose him
in the monologue yeah and then at the
end of the story he said
um he's in his dressing room there's a
knock at the door and and the door opens
and Churchill's there and he goes my
Noble Lord Hamlet may I use your
bathroom
he's like what a fitting coder now and
now